Matthew Mian is a director of
programs and the Worsham teaching fellow
at Hillsdale colleges Kirby Center in
Washington DC he earned his PhD at the
University of Dallas where he wrote a
dissertation on Shakespeare's vision for
leadership education in his
collaborative play Sir Thomas More dr.
Mian has been approved his fellow at the
Claremont Institute and is a fellow of
the Center for Thomas More studies and a
reader at the full girl library he has
served as a speechwriter and
communications consultant for civic
leaders around the country he is the
author of mr. means mildly amusing
mythical mammals an illustrated book of
poems please join me in welcoming dr.
Matthew Mian
[Applause]
thank you very much
applied mathematics it's awesome here
shall it talk I guess Matt Bell has a
sense of humor in a Paris together but
that's good that's the liberal arts
thank you all for coming
thank you Matt Bell for shepherding me
out here and thank you all for your
support of Hillsdale particularly our
new venture which I've been a part of
out and Washington DC the Steve and Amy
Van Andel Graduate School of Government
I got the unbelievable honor to teach
the very first classes very first
classes very first class this fall
and it was just wonderful we started
with Antigone and the book of Proverbs
and Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and
it's happening right on Capitol Hill and
it's it's been a really great honor in
my life so thank you all for supporting
Hillsdale
[Applause]
before I speak directly about Thomas
More's utopia I'd like to start with
three drop jokes about Marxist
socialists when I repeat myself from the
satirical humor site McSweeney's usually
left-leaning
but nevertheless see if you can spot
what all three of the jokes have in
common
the first one knock knock who's there a
Marxist socialists a Marxist socialist
who a Marxist socialist who wants to
give you a pamphlet about class struggle
I'll try another one sorry yeah what did
one Marxist socialist say to another
like you I also advocate a proletarian
revolution culminating in collective
ownership last one bare with me
what do you get when you cross a Marxist
with a socialist to people who generally
feel that the value of a commodity is
equal to its socially necessary
labour-time they're great fun at parties
I think that's the takeaway here what
the humorous that McSweeney's is getting
at is that the famous German socialist
is what the famous German socialist
Friedrich Engels knew was a distinct
trait of German socialists where all
this sort of began in the introduction
to his English edition of socialism
utopian and scientific and there he's
borrowing from the word coined by Thomas
More there which is a collected series
of shocker pamphlets by the way they're
great fun at parties that give you
pamphlets poor Friedrich seems defensive
before his witty English audience when
he writes this as is well known we
Germans are of a terribly ponderous
Grund lish kite okay radical profundity
or profound radicality whatever you may
like to call it when you learn that
grundle ich kite basically means
thoroughness that's all it means right
the next line becomes unintelligible
tensional hilarious angles continues to
expound thoroughly on the meaning of
thoroughness this way whenever any one
of us expounds what he considers a new
doctrine he has first to elaborate it
into an all compromising system he has
to prove that both the principles of
logic and the fundamental laws of the
universe had existed from all eternity
for no other purpose than to ultimately
lead to this newly discovered crowning
theory and it gets even more ridiculous
after that when this father of modern
German socialism we find out was trying
to satirize another socialist and after
going through another page of this he
says finally with a little grunt lished
kite of his own anyhow the systematic
comprehensiveness of my opponent gave me
the opportunity of developing in
opposition to him and in a more
connected form than had previously been
done the views held by karl marx and
myself on this great variety of subjects
like I said Thanksgiving dinner just
isn't the same without uncle Friedrich
arguing with good old cousin mr.
professor dr. II during this is how they
speak they speak heavy ponderous
monologues massive systems it's not a
witty group in short German socialists
are not known for their wit and
Friedrich Engels knew it well enough to
be sheepish about it before the witty
British audience he was seeking to
persuade in that essay without arguing
here permit me to assert that a people
tend to be witty if they've been led so
by the witty examples of their famous
writers speakers their poets historians
and statesmen and if they're very
fortunate even their philosophers not
incidental to our purpose today Thomas
More was all of these things but let me
be more thorough and give you the
testimony of one of mors own
contemporaries Thomas More is a man of
an Angels wit and singular learning he
is a man of many excellent virtues I
know not his fellow for where is the man
in whom is so many goodly virtues of
that gentleness lowliness and after
ability and as time requires a man of
marvelous mirth and pastimes and
sometimes of steadfast gravity a man for
all seasons those were the words of
Robert Whittington who was a liberal
arts teacher and translator of Cicero
and Seneca to Roman philosophers
statesmen orders deeply favored by
Thomas More and featured in Moore's most
famous and famously misunderstood utopia
the phrase man for all seasons suits
more well so well that it became the
hallmark of the 20th century
understanding of him in his lifetime
Moore was Speaker of the House of
Commons and while he was Speaker of the
House of Commons he secured the first
right of free speech not for the whole
of London or the whole of England but
just for the Parliament so they could
speak freely to the king without and
risking their lives he was also the Lord
Chancellor of England stepping up as
Shakespeare put it up nearly to his
country's head right below the king
essentially effectively running the
government for him and he was a famous
poet historian and essayist as well as a
brilliant lawyer and an attentive father
and after his execution and death Moore
was praised before Queen Elizabeth
that's Henry the eighth's father who he
only opposed and the entire Parliament
at st. Paul's Cathedral in Shakespeare's
time and named a saint of both the
Anglican and Catholic churches in our
own time that to me is the sort of the
great combo trick like I don't know how
you do that Church of England and the
Roman Church but anyway all of these
impressive achievements of more aside in
1954 the playwright Robert bolt wrote a
man for all seasons about Moore's artful
and courageous resistance to King Henry
the eighth
who violated the Magna Carta and his
coronation oath in order to divorce his
wife and declare himself the head of
both church and state Moore's refusal to
accept this Caesar Oh Pape ISM of King
Henry landed more in the Tower of London
and then on the chopping block likewise
it is that same stalwart objection by
more to the combination of state and
Church authority that sent the Puritan
pilgrims to Plymouth and the Catholic
pilgrims
to Maryland the film version man for all
seasons won eight Academy Awards in 1967
including Best Picture and director and
in 1990 the Law Society of Great Britain
named him lawyer of the millennium and
Pope John Paul the second named him the
patron of statesman for the Catholic
Church worldwide despite all these
various accolades and honors over the
centuries
despite being a principal source of a
number of Shakespeare's plays despite
being considered by Jonathan Swift to be
quote the person of the greatest virtue
these islands ever produced it is
nevertheless true what Robert bolts
Moore's character says to a
simple-minded Spaniard diplomat when he
presumes to know what Moore thinks about
the politics of the day the Spaniard but
should views Sir Thomas More are well
known which more contradict saying my
views are much guessed at so to today
with careless unhistorical and confusing
melodramas like HBO's the tutors and
BBC's will fall Moore's view remains
much guest:and but still very poorly
known and that's especially true when it
comes to his most complex and
confounding ironic work utopia written
1516 published throughout the continent
and England and wildly popular from the
start I mean it was the book of Europe
at the time sort of we have hunger games
they had utopia sort of different world
Moore makes himself a character in the
dialogue of utopia along with his friend
and fellow Christian humanist Peter
Giles
but it's a tricky dialogue that has
within it both a monologue about a
different dialogue from before the
dialogue and a different monologue
within the dialogue that's longer than
the rest of the entire dialogue except
that the monologue is technically a very
long part of the dialogue that's a
little greenish guide for you
the two major monologues in Utopia are
given by the third interlocutor in the
dialogue a strange and passionate
character he's a traveler and scholar
named Rafiel Hitler day who claims to
have lived on the amazing island of
utopia which means no place by the way
and with its novel and he says truly
excellent political institutions the
text of utopia is divided into two books
and raviel Hitler day dominates both of
them book two of utopia is almost
exclusively Raphael's long and extremely
thorough account of the laws habits and
customs of the utopians and even though
book 2 technically has mores characters
speak at the very end it is really Rea
feel hella day's monologue with the
other speakers reduced to mere onlookers
mislead a frustrates any authentic
dialogue at that point and I'm kind of
reminded of the bad guy syndrome from
The Incredibles you remember that line
you sly dog you caught me monologuing
right the bad guys in the comic books
are always monologuing about their evil
plans there's something about that in
Rayfield Hitler day he just gets going
and you can't stop them this chronic
mono loggers name means both healer of
God that's refill Raphael and skilled
speaker of nonsense hit low deus in
greek by giving the character a name
like that more sets the attentive reader
on guard to suspect that whatever
Rayfield Hitler day is going to say
about this island and its institutions
utopia
you can bet it's going to be a mixture
of sense and nonsense and so it is but
you'd need to have the wit to see that
more is not being ponderous literal and
radical but rather witty ironic and
subtle to understand mores utopia
properly the habit of socialist Marxist
communist grunlich height but again I
repeat myself is not very helpful
because that cast of mind and cast of
character only stifles the width
required to see well the practical
political and actual world in which we
live and work now I want to take a
moment to apologize for this talk
because it combines a few things that
don't mix very well presenting a talk on
both heavy and sad socialism it's very
grim dark thing Matt bell talking about
hell sort of set that up for us and then
we've got to combine it with Moore's
witty and wise mirthful utopia it's like
serving a peanut butter sandwich mixed
with pickled herring or making a Netflix
special featuring the art of laughter or
the joy of laughter and oral surgery or
it's as if you dressed up for Halloween
as someone pretending to be you
what if you're puzzled at that sort of
ironic and contradictory humor where you
thought it was going one way and it goes
another welcome to Thomas More's utopia
it's a very puzzling book that gives you
the distinct sense that you are not
always in on the joke at least not at
first
but that the humor is nevertheless there
to help the reader to more than just
laughs in other words it's ironic jokes
are not very socialist because as we all
know socialist jokes are only funny if
everybody gets it
wait for it no in fact utopia is so
puzzling that it's been famously
nicknamed the statesman's puzzle yet the
book is less and less puzzling the
whittier and more ironically humorous a
lens you use to read it on the other
hand utopia is far more puzzling for
people who have a bad case of GRU dalish
guides that ponderous seriousness that
can't handle dialogue and double meaning
the great critic of socialism and
communism Alexander Solzhenitsyn put it
this way no one would ever dare accuse
Stalin of having a sense of humor
they're not known for their sense of
humor with 50 million dead I suppose
that joke is always sort of hashtag too
soon but it it's there
they're dark deep serious grim fellows
and more has even famously witty hasn't
was even famously witty in the hour of
his death so here's a the difference
between Stalin and more unlike the
brutal humorous unfunny socialist
communist Stalin again I repeat myself
who murdered many millions the Christian
humanist poet lawyer statesman loved to
laugh he referred to himself as having
the nature of half a jig lit and more
you guys know what a jig lit is it's if
you ever go to Italy or Mexico the
street vendors will carve these little
wooden dentures and the way you open
them they scrape and
so it's like a little like laughing
denture like that's how more referred to
himself in his books it's like I can't
stop laughing even though I'm this very
serious Statesman please don't tickle my
funny bone in his lifetime Moore was
famous for using humor both to mock his
opponents not always with sarcasm mind
you but very often also with witty irony
that was difficult to defeat and that
pricked the conscience when Sir more
rose to the national stage as Speaker of
the House he was known as master mock
and more was even famously witty like I
said on the scaffold among other jests
when rising to the scaffold and the
chopping block he joked his own headsman
I pray you let my me lay my beard over
the block lest you should cut it
the reason being of course that my beard
has not offended the king as a moment of
death more mentioned not a few times by
the way in his writings that his letters
that his last name in both Latin and
Greek means fool and his first name
didymus Thomas means twin or double also
it means Mulberry but that's really
neither here nor there
after Moore's death in the times that
follow he was honored by Shakespeare
with a very favourable collaborative
play called Sir Thomas More you heard I
did my dissertation on that play which
Shakespeare co-wrote with five other
popular playwrights of his day so
imagine if Spielberg Nolan you you know
pick your pick your like top Lucas big
big names Whedon all got together and
said okay we were going to produce this
play this the the censor said no you may
not because it had a riot scene and they
didn't want anyone thinking about
rioting in London but it was
nevertheless a professionally produced
or written play by some of the top
playwrights more well it's my place here
in it true to biographical accounts
Moore is completely serious when he must
be quelling a citywide riot in
ministering justice for the realm of the
Privy Council of the King but otherwise
he's constantly dropping witty mocks
funny puns and clever and ironic jokes
for his friends desiderio sir a smus and
even very subtly for his friend King
Henry the eighth always with an eye to
both their delight and their instruction
more even stages a humble little
morality play within the play for his
friend the Lord Mayor of London called
the marriage of wit and wisdom indeed
throughout the play more jests in this
witty wise way staging humorous plays of
his own that contain high moral matter
for instance when imprisoned in the
tower on the eve of execution Hills the
tea tells the guard a low potty humor
joke that has a high and subtle lesson
about tyranny
when meant explicitly for the king
should he ever hear tell of it which
more rightly suspects he will as the
tower guard character puts it marveling
aloud in the play in life and death
still marry Sir Thomas More in other
words the author of utopia knew how to
laugh how to mock how to jest how to
speak doubly and ironically even when
discussing serious life-and-death
matters of political justice I've got a
little spider
it's a comic prompt life and Jeff death
questions like justice and tyranny he
knew how to both love and mock himself
his friends and his King and by the way
if as I'll argue here Moore was a proto
Republican that wanted to see England
move from a monarchy to a full-blown
republic you'd better learn how to make
fun of a king without getting your head
cut off right how else do you do it
short of murdering your fellow citizens
but you wouldn't no mores utopia holds
up social it's for ambivalence scrutiny
ironic mockery and subtle correction if
you insist on witless Lee viewing the
world through the lens of an ironic
literal-minded stripped down unadorned
socialist Grund leash kite
for example if you took a chilly turn
through the Alexandrov ski garden in the
Kremlin in Moscow you will find a
monument and ornate obelisk
commemorating the Romanovs or czars of
yesteryear with carved granite tens of
feet tall and shining gold-leafed double
eagle pyramidion cap the obelisk feels
very Czarist very ornate like those
potentates that share both and sort of
the east and the west that you that
ruled Russia for hundreds of years and
yet it was only erected in 2013 or
rather it was restored by Putin Lenin
erased the original ordering soviet
riflemen literally to shoot off the
original commemorative texts in his 1918
campaign of soviet propaganda shortly
after the Bolshevik Revolution Lenin
placed a replaced the old Czarist
monument or really just defaced it with
the brutalist and ponderously named
monument obelisk two outstanding
thinkers and personalities of the
struggle for the liberation of workers
no gold leaf on the soviet monument no
double eagle just a single heavy cold
stone
I just got bit by a spider that's right
no it's a drone from AOC the Soviet
obelisk was simply a list
the Soviets liked keeping lists
commemorating revolutionary thinkers and
activists that pave the way for the
Bolsheviks moment of triumph and the new
socialist era of glorious transition to
full communism for the USSR which stands
for lest we forget the Union of Soviet
Socialist Republics in the precise
middle of the vertical list of names
below Karl Marx and our very thorough
friend Frederick Engels and amidst
French art anarchists and German
Socialist Party leaders Lenin and his
Soviet propaganda saw fit to carve the
name of Thomas More no doubt on account
of his famous and famously misread book
utopia and its fictitious island which
has abolished private property and is
said to have neither poverty nor envy
nor strife now this stark obelisk like
so much of Soviet propaganda is a lie
and like the rest of soap the Soviet
empires House of Lies the obelisk was
bulldozed unceremoniously after
communism --zf all but the lie of mores
utopia that it's socialists still stands
if one thoughtlessly skims utopia or
wilfully cherry-picks from its lengthy
and ironic dialogue it's possible to
think the author advocates socialism and
the abolition of private property after
all Rayfield hit the day the dubious
traveler in the dialogue who more
compares to the famous liar Odysseus
does offer the following lengthy speech
this is Rachel hesitate speaking at
length groaned Lycia gate the most
prudent man that is Plato in his
Republic easily foresaw that there could
be only one way to public well-being by
decree in the Equality of possessions
which I do not think could ever be
observed when individuals have private
ownership for when each person by a
definite right and title remember that
sweeps up as much as can beat to himself
the
higher supply of goods no matter how
large is divided up among only a few
persons leaving scarcity for everyone
else it generally happens then that each
group really deserves the destiny of the
other group since the fewer rapacious
shameless and useless while the many by
contrast are modest and simple and by
their daily industry more kindly
disposed to the public interest than
they are to themselves and this is why
I'm fully persuaded that Goods cannot be
distributed in an equitable or just way
or that anything can turn out well in
human affairs
unless ownership is completely abolished
and on the other hand as long as it
remains so also will remain an anxiety
producing an inescapable load of
hardships and poverty for the largest
part and the best part by far of the
human race okay long quote straight up
socialism but to think that this is
Moore's position or that it is the final
verdict of the dialogue of utopia would
be like witless lis cherry-picking
Macbeth's
act 5 despair speech including that
concluding that Shakespeare and the
entire tragedy of Macbeth agree with the
character Macbeth when he says that life
is a tale told by an idiot full of sound
and fury signifying nothing
perhaps Macbeth had read too many
socialist pamphlets that day would the
socialist interpretation of mores subtle
and dialogic text work more careless and
more dare I say at Thoreau we wouldn't
be in this position it is perhaps more
than simply an amusing irony then that
the character of Rayfield Hitler day
loves overwhelming his interlocutors
with very thorough very lengthy
monologues not unlike Frederick Engels
and his fellow socialist doctor II
during those who think so simply and
simplistically as to suggest seriously
and literally that we ought to remove
all private property to solve our
political ills are the same thoughts
that Kant for lack of wit follow a
dialogue and can't engage in one either
like syndrome from Brad Birds
Incredibles they're too busy monologuing
literary wit listening conversing too
turning seeing double meaning irony
humor paradox the habit of looking at
life at human behavior or at the city
and realizing that once before your eyes
is a tale told by no idiot which
signifies much more than nothing but
that's the position of atheist
materialism that undergirds socialism is
there's nothing but meat in front of you
you don't have to have a double vision
you don't see the Providence of God you
don't see an immortal soul you don't see
mind principle spirit you just see meat
on a rock hurtling through the dark it's
a very monologic way of thinking about
the world ok that was pretty ponderous
so these ponderous and thorough
monologue errs masters of ghoulish kite
tend to lack the subtlety and
receptivity that is the wynt required
for wisdom for good judgment about what
people say about texts that people write
and about the cities and societies that
we need to build that is the socialist
character type which more Lampoon's in
the person of Rayfield Hitler day in
utopia tends to have grown lish kite
when expounding their own theories of
utopian and scientific socialism but
also tend to lack that same thoroughness
when it comes to being attentive to
reality itself and what other people are
telling them and that reality is that
Moore's character in Utopia strongly
objects to reveal Hitler days socialist
institutions both in book 1 and in book
2 of utopia here's Moore's objection
from book 1 that he had to wait to give
because Rachel Hitler day went on and on
for a long time before he could finally
get a word in edgewise in the dialog but
on the contrary Moore said it seems to
me that life can never be lived with any
convenience where all things are owned
in common for how could there be a good
supply of things with everybody trying
to get out of work not being urged by
the profit motive and becoming lazy
by relying on the work of others but
even if they are spurred to work by the
scarcity when nobody is able lawfully to
protect as his own what he has acquired
is it not inevitable that everyone will
suffer from perpetual murder and
Sedition especially when the authority
and reverence of magistrates is gone for
how there could be any place for that
when the people cannot be distinguished
among themselves in any way i cannot
imagine and yet despite this very clear
counter-argument and others from thomas
moore the character in his own dialogue
the bogus claim that mores utopia is
really a work of socialist and communist
theory is still proudly trumpeted both
from on high in the ivory tower
for instance Cambridge University's
Terry Eagleton and from on low and the
digital swamps of Wikipedia on the
surprise surprise entry for utopian
socialism now to be fair it may be that
utopia is considered a socialist book
because at least some socialists trained
as they are for straightforward
scientific accounts of political economy
and radical revolution cannot read a
text for metaphor and irony being able
to read for subtlety takes a good deal
of liberal arts training like the kind
we offer here at Hillsdale perhaps it's
as simple as to say they are just too
literal minded lacking a literary
education in true wit or maybe they're
just mentally drained from all the
pamphleteering maybe tend to think they
get some excited for some reason being
able to read for subtlety right that
skill not being there maybe it's just
that they actually don't they have
subtlety but they actually refuse to
read for subtlety in a way that takes
utopia's ironic and mocking presentation
of their own position seriously because
they're more interested in the political
project of socialism than being truthful
about what other people have said that
is they don't mind lying to you that was
Solzhenitsyn's big point in the Gulag
Archipelago
I remember professor John grant the
politics department here came out to
Kirby fears back somewhat the lie just
they will lie they want to hold the lie
and Schultz and it was like you gotta
speak the truth or perhaps they simply
can't bear to be mocked so they just
block out the subtle reasoning maybe
it's subconscious another possible
obstacle to reading utopia wittily is
that most socialists think too little
about politics and think much more
narrowly about economic questions
concerning the means of production they
tended to ride political and
constitutional fixes as merely bourgeois
institutions half measures to be pitied
that must be swept away by the
revolution as soon as possible that
means they do not consider rightly nor
respect the fact that Thomas More is in
fact a proto Republican he's a proto
Republican thinker that is more's ironic
criticism of private property in the
voice of Rayfield Hitler Day is not the
radical attacks of socialists on a
widely distributed and legally held
democratic system of private property
generosity and equality like we have or
strive to have here in the US rather
Moore's teachings on private property
are attempting to moderate the radically
oligarchic position of the landed
aristocracy of England I'm reminded of
one of my teachers another Hillsdale
professor dr. Tom West when he would
lament the lock-up of federal lands by
the US Senate and the Department of
Interior that couldn't be accessed for
private property ownership by the
citizenry instead imagine Miss Moore was
looking at an unelected Senate namely
the House of Lords the members of which
personally owned the land and have
permanent claim to it in perpetuity for
their descendants for ever and ever amen
it's not surprising that radical
socialists can't see Moore's attempt to
moderate the claims of property
ownership so that property could be
treated in a way more in line with
common sense and natural reason changing
the laws to something closer to what we
have now but socialists probably do see
at least that Moore is honoring
admirable
qualities of at least some socialists
and some or some accounts of what we
might call soft socialism for instance
detachment from material goods like we
should be detached I mean we can't take
it with us so you don't want your things
to own you you want to own your things
that's very admirable right love of the
poor that's very good
see Jesus and yes ridicule ridicule for
the folly filled idea that you and your
family have a given plot of land by
nature in other words the ideology
behind landed aristocracy which we
Americans expressly forbid in our
constitution in part because of the
witty proto Republican counsels of
writers like more but socialists don't
see these subtle dynamics in Utopia
because those ironies detail and serve
the purpose of weakening the claims of
nobility and encouraging the Civic
spiritedness and of generosity and
friendship and a proper witty and
accurate reading of utopia does not
support the socialists historical
narratives nor their radical policy to
abolish all or most private property for
the sake of socialist control the means
of production socialists seem not to
suspect mores strong yet subtle mockery
of their very dangerous intellectual
vices their love of monologues of having
their way of living like kings and their
opinions unhampered by the messy details
of actual political reality it's true
that more respects the socialist
character type rayful Hitler days first
name does mean healer of God just so the
socialist character type as an admirably
ardent desire for perfection that's
commendable is worth praising for
society where no one suffers never gonna
happen but obviously it's something that
theoretically you would like to see
we're all hoping for heaven for
something like that where every tear
shall be wiped away and we're Ingles
Singles put it where everyone holds
quote the common property of all to be
worked for the common good of all or as
Matt Bell was quoting earlier right
heaven but you don't even need it
it all sounds nice it sounds lovely
socialism does sound good
witty Sir Thomas Moore was aware of just
how lovely
socialism sounded but just as it takes a
certain sharp sided wit to see when an
offer is too good to be true
likewise I just saw a billboard driving
from the Detroit Airport today free
college we just the devil all the
billboard said some address you're like
probably not something's up hold on your
wallet
likewise more C's in Utopia to train our
seeks in Utopia to train our own wit to
see the difference between a political
order that sounds good and one that
actually looks good in reality one that
is good and not just good in theory
that's why the proto socialist character
of Rayfield Hitler Day isn't just God's
healer nor simply a skilled speaker in
nonsense he has both names together
because nothing that is is all bad nor
in this world at least all good in all
respects at all times this sort of
double vision this ability to see
something admirable in socialist
impulses while also realizing the
dangerous and tyrannical deeply
tyrannical impulses that lurk beneath
them this sort of witty wise habit of
looking at life and politics to see what
it is what you wish it could be and the
difference between Prudential political
improvements and radically dangerous
dangerously radical thoroughly stupid
and stupidly thorough political change
is revealed in Utopia as the difference
between dialogue and monologue between
more and half a day and between what we
might call Republican wit and tyrannical
and socialist grundle ich kite and mores
utopia centuries before the full
flowering of socialism and communism
offers a deep meditation on prudential
politics and a powerful and witty
critique of such thoroughgoing tyrannies
the sort that is enslaved to a witless
idea of perfection
into the sound of their own monologic
voices at the close of utopia
after a long tale from his ledee full of
ironic and conflicting statements
designed to help the reader think about
politics and justice mores own character
thinks that the laws and customs of the
Autopia --nz seem very absurdly
established but he says most of all in
there that feature which is the
principle foundation of their whole
structure i mean their common life and
subsistence without any exchange of
money utopias lack of customs and laws
protecting private property and commerce
more emphasizes quote utterly overthrows
all the nobility taking from the nobles
right that word if you take away private
property of all the people of the
Commonwealth the Commons you overthrow
utterly overthrow all the nobility
magnificence
that's a kingly term splendor another
kingly and majesty another kingly term
which are in the estimation of the
common people the true glories and
ornaments of the Commonwealth the Latin
here is more telling and forgive me
who'd pública asked open e o decade'
earthquake ornamental ray publica for
Republican Thomas More is carefully
wittily and subtly a champion of
democratic republicanism in an age of
monarchs and monologues a writer
responsible for a masterwork of Western
literature full of Socratic irony
designed to educate a free people for
personal virtue and self-government by
means of a city and speech like that of
Plato's in the Republic or more like
Cicero's in the de república it was this
man Thomas More whom Lenin in one of
history's monumental ironies deigned to
call comrade I imagine that the wily and
witty Sir Thomas More the Statesman who
Shakespeare tells us loved to be Mary
would have received this honor if he
were alive today with a wry smile and
his trademark eye
he might have said something like this
Thank You comrades I had thought that
the Union of Soviet Socialist Republics
would have better left me out in the
cold but you have honored me in a way no
good man should ever hope for you can
make those kinds of jokes all day if you
read utopia as many times as I have
that's what it's designed to do make a
fashion your wit shape your whip now
I'll stop monologuing and start
dialoguing with you thank you
[Applause]
thank you dr. Mian we now have time for
Q&A please make your way to the
microphone if you have a question that's
right mm-hmm yeah there's a number of
translations there's ones free online
there's a really excellent translation
it's actually coming out from the
essential works of Thomas Moore this
January which was put together over the
course of 20 years with a professor
Jerry Wagner who I studied with but also
his co-editor is dr. Steven Smith here
at Hillsdale so it's it's actually that
books coming out in January with all the
best translation the best notes that
really explain what is going on in this
text and all of mors major texts that's
coming January and for a a mind of this
caliber who's written this many classics
and has had this much influence this
happens once every hundred years so
that's something to pay attention to in
January but that's the best translation
I've seen it I've heckled over some of
its footnotes with Steve a couple times
Ben that's coming out in January yes
please
oh sorry
the long walk will take one while he's
getting there one please thank you for
your talk today um I remember you know
I'm getting to the point in my life
where I'm thinking long ago when the
dinosaurs were young I used to tell my
daughter uh I remember our this is more
of a current cultural thing but I think
it's tangentially related to Thomas
Moore that we had we had a richness of
comedy in our in our culture from from
broad slapstick to to incisive
intellectual wit and it seems like today
there's no humor because the Socialists
have taken over the mechanisms of comedy
and through this PC nonsense which is
nothing more than an intellectual and a
humor straitjacket is you know economy's
not funny it's either scatological or
it's it's just dreadfully more of a dull
and malicious I just want to comment you
know from it um
yes there are comics I think often times
out some really excellent wit is wasted
on scatological material some brilliant
people who decide to go hide and some
filth that is sort of non really Oh fit
for dignified enjoyment right so there's
that problem I think there is still wit
out there it's oftentimes submerged in
some filth but you do see some rebellion
right there is and the comics and the
comedians are sort of finding that even
the director of the latest Joker movie
in protest Joker is actually a silent
Grunder skites
type film that's his ponderous dark
brooding thing he's he's a comic
director but he said I can't do comedy
for now so you're just gonna have to
deal with that almost like a protest a
sort of laughter striking
so I don't know if the clowns are gonna
save us but there is sort of a some
tomfoolery that's gaining steam I think
the inspiration from marx and engels
communism coming from the sweatshops of
england in the 1820s 30s 40s and 50s
where does thomas moore get his
inspiration from for writing about
socialism the way he did question so the
enclosure movement is actually featured
and discussed in book 1 of the dialogue
and for for him he's very upset with the
nobility making property write claims
evicting peasants who lived in the same
family home for a thousand years but
because it wasn't on a piece of paper
and it wasn't enforced by the House of
Law Lords the the common people's common
wealth their property their homes were
judged worthless so that gets him
thinking about radical claims to
property ownership of the Lord's so he's
taking aim at the lords who kicked all
these people off to in order to make
sheepfolds but what's happened is
they've lost their homes so they can't
farm and they wind up taken to the
streets turning to crime and hangings
are like spike thousands of percent like
it's just a bloodbath every day they're
hanging people so Moore's responding to
that but if you don't pay attention you
go oh look he's mad at private
properties you know he loves private
property thinks it's been violated by
the nobility of specious private
property claim of the elite has robbed
all of the peasants that they're
commonly held homes for a thousand years
so I've not read the Utopia yet or
Plato's Republic I've just begun reading
The Gulag Archipelago but I have read
quite a majority of Plato's Timaeus and
Critias which tells the story of
Atlantis which is there would be the
usual story we've all heard some version
of is that it was a utopia type paradise
that fell because it turned to decadence
and just filth and was of course
destroyed in tsunami or flood that's the
very end of the story but the also the
more moral I guess and social aspect a
lesson of the story was that a utopia in
the paradise sense at least if you're
talking about a government or socialism
either one of any sort is that it's
ultimately unattainable and untreatable
because it falls apart and is badly
managed so much that there's nothing you
can do with it
and that the question is so in this set
in this way are the two stories of of
Atlantis and utopia is is that am i
accurate about the similarity and what
seems to be the goal of socialism is
when you ask the Socialists they have no
vision so what is their coherent plan
and are they I mean is that a current
similarity there was a lot of girlish
guide for an awesome question
[Laughter]
that you're you're absolutely right to
see courteous the way he says I've got
this place I gonna tell you about that
seems very strange but every word of
it's true so it's very much grateful if
a day I swear no place exists utopia
exists sure buddy right he's a travelers
kind of sketchy and he also says it was
his ninety year old grandfather who told
that to him when he was eight sir like
what really you're gonna have a detailed
political programme from that exchange
so it's it's that same kind of dubious
I've got a perfect ideal that's very
questionable so yeah I think mores
definitely he translated Plato's
Republic I think twice and definitely
read a number of dialects to try to
think deeply about constitutionalism
politics republican government and
utopia is in part a product of a very
sustained study of his own of Plato so
you're totally right there it's a good
catch and you're you're spot on what do
they want
I think Moore's got their number in
Rayfield Hitler day what he really wants
is everyone to praise him everyone to
say you're a genius everyone to more or
less put him up pay for him right and
say yeah this guy is brilliant he's got
a great plan hopefully one day we can do
it but you know let's give him some
power let's have him rule libido
dominant a the desire to dominate other
people right Gnosticism I've got a
secret teaching it's really hard to
explain and you don't understand science
its history it's complicated it's just
give me all your property please
I really think it gets down to those
kinds of simple really dangerous desires
but they're under a giant just
smokescreen yes of but but pink smoke
and green smoke and glitter and bombs
it's and and then they fall for the
image no I'm really doing this good
thing so
my turn
I'll ask you a simple question do you
think socialism has ever been achieved
it sounds to me it's a fantasy and
remain sister fantasy as far as any
advanced society do I think it's ever
been achieved correct no no I mean if
achievement is a one minute sentiment of
a number of people with a document in a
room then sure I'm sure it's been
achieved a number of times but no we've
never had a working state it's actually
been socialistic in the promise it's
always been an apparent socialism which
is that's the kind of double vision you
need no please I agree with you because
what happens there's always a small
number controlling a massive number
whether it's a monarchy or or whatever
it seems to come down to that and
socialism is another variety of that
agree thank you
thank you
you